gas prices are at an all-time high here
in southern nevada as our state ranks
the second highest in the nation and
those that drive for a living are really
feeling the effects of this so how are
they coping with it is the question
madison kimbrough joins us live tonight
near desert inn in the i-15 with details
madison
nevada's regular gas is right now at 5
52 a gallon that's according to aaa and
for drivers here in las vegas many say
it's put a halt on their day-to-day
lives especially for those in the
rideshare industry uber driver joe
vaughn has been driving for five years
and says while he has been busy the cost
of gas has really put a dent in his
wallet and feels like he is making less
of a profit than he had been before but
as a retiree doesn't feel like he has
many options and when it comes to his
colleagues many don't know if they will
make it through the summer months
i have a friend who just started driving
just recently and he's i don't know if
he's going to take a pause because i
don't know what his options are but he's
not happy about it nobody is nobody's
happy about these the gas prices are
driving all kinds of other inflation i
want to auto part i want spark plugs i
want the things that go with driving a
car the prices of them are all gone up
the national average for gas is four
dollars and 91 cents a gallon and triple
a said the cost of a barrel of oil is
near 120 dollars that's almost double
from last august as increased oil
demands have surpassed our supply other
rideshare drivers i spoke to say they
have seen an increase in locals using
their services because they don't want
to fill up their own gas tanks reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now